it's a series that's always been at home
on PC we built it on PC at the beginning
of time back when we were working on
origins and with Inquisition we've kind
of kept that legacy so the combat had
was created specifically for PC so gives
a lot of the maneuverability that you
want as a PC player the tactical camera
and pause and play is just like you
would expect from origins you'll be
super super pleased with it but it just
creates a nice interface to interact
with the world just turned 40 this year
so I think it's safe to say i've been
gaming on pc for at least 30 years i
think with inquisition together we've
done a pretty good job of keeping a lot
of the surprises under wraps but how
they all fit together and how the story
plays out I think he's going to surprise
some folks so for me there's that quiet
anticipation of going all that that's
really cool let's let's see who finds it
we said so we're going to do quadrupeds
and they said oh you can't do that you
can't have four-legged creatures in this
thing won't work and we said well we
know but we need dragons with a bears we
need horses it's been fun to talk to the
other teams that support frostbite in
our part of the prospecting because
they've had I think a lot of fun helping
us push the boundaries of the engine to
do things like that that were never use
cases for the original at PAX not this
year but last year the first time that
we ever showed the game live we didn't
tell anybody that we were coming and I
remember sitting in that auditorium just
like shaky and I was sitting next to my
friend mark and he was laughing because
I was shaking hysterically because it
was like just about to go on screen and
you know things weren't quite right
audio didn't come on and then it finally
started playing and you know we hit a
and it just went smooth as silk it's
amazing and to see the smiles and laughs
and tears around me as people are
playing through like it's yeah it's
great feeling
you